airlines as you know still dealing with
a major pilot shortage demand for their
work it is growing local aviation
schools now encouraging people to enter
this profession bianca holman joining us
live with kind of their push to get
people to join up bianca good morning
i've been here i've been learning so
much about the aviation industry i
learned that you don't have to be 17. so
if you've got a high school student who
loves planes loves being in the air they
may want to consider starting up now and
also of course you can be a career
changer career changer and i do have
learned that 65 is the cut off age but
aaron you're not 65.
but you tell me that you're a career
changer so what sparked you to go into
the field now and kind of become a
student
i grew up with my grandpa flying and it
was always kind of a passion of mine and
just the right circumstances in life
dictated that i could do this and
i just went down and found the best
flight school i could find and here i am
yeah that's so brave and courageous to
kind of start over again and start a new
career so i understand lots of hours you
got to get up in this plane and fly so
much so tell me what has been the most
challenging thing that you've noticed
being in flight school for you what has
what has that been
for me the challenging thing is just i
have a family and kids and kind of
organizing my time but
it's totally doable
you just organize yourself well and get
through the material and
try to get to the those flying times
because those are the most fun yeah and
also you told me about this major test
that you just took the book is about
this thick right it's like studying for
the sat or the lsat or whatever the
major test is so how was that for you
the testing and you know just kind of
the rigor that's here it was good i
haven't been a student for a while and
getting back into that book knowledge
and just making sure you retain all that
knowledge so that it's practical
um it went really well yeah and also
what about the opportunities you know
like you said you have a family got to
care for so you know this is a major
investment for you uh you know are you
encouraged about those opportunities
because there's there's a need for you
all absolutely um my kids are excited
for me to be able to take them up on a
plane someday and uh i'm gonna make it
happen yeah for sure well thank you so
much for chatting with us and again
there's there's a huge need we're going
to continue to talk about uh just all
the opportunities that are available in
the aviation industry and of course this
is just one of the several schools
around the valley we're here at all in
aviation so we're going to continue to
share more about
just the status of the industry thus far
back to you guys in the studio